JUST A FEW MOMENTS WITH
EXCLUSIVE REACTION TO BIDEN
SPEECH, BUT FIRST, AND WHAT FELT
AT SOMETIMES LIKE AN NEVER
ENDING ZOOM CALL WITH
PROFESSIONAL THE 2020 VIRTUAL
DNC FINALLY, MERCIFULLY WRAPS.
AFTER ALL THE DEMOCRATS AND
GAUZY TRIBUTES TO JOE AND THE
SHAMELESS LIES ABOUT TRAUMA,
WHILE WE ARE LEFT WITH IS A
RECOGNITION THAT THIS IS A PARTY
THAT HAS NOTHING SINCE 2016.
THINK ABOUT IT, TO ANSWER
TRUMP’S POPULAR APPEAL, THEY
NOMINATED A GUY FIRST RAN FOR
PRESIDENT 33 YEARS AGO.
I GUY THAT HAS BEEN HANGING
AROUND WASHINGTON SINCE THE
EARLY 70s.
IT A MAN WHOSE GRANDFATHER
APPEAL, NOTWITHSTANDING, IT
EPITOMIZES THE WORD TRUMP.
THEN ADDING INSULT TO INJURY,
THEY THINK YOU ARE SO STUPID
THAT YOU WILL VOTE FOR THEM EVEN
IF YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HE IS
ACTUALLY DOING TO TACKLE OUR
TOUGHEST CHALLENGES.
>> THEY WILL GET THIS PANDEMIC
UNDER CONTROL.
LIKE JOE DID WHEN HE HELP ME
MANAGE H1N1.
AND PREVENT AN EBOLA OUTBREAK
FROM REACHING OUR SHORES.
>> JOE WILL BRING US TOGETHER TO
END PANDEMIC AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
ONE.
>> CONVENIENCE, YOU’VE GOT TO GO
AND DEAL WITH THE FACTS AND GO
TO WORK.
OUR PARTIES UNITED IN OFFERING
YOU A VERY DIFFERENT CHOICE.
>> Laura: CHOSE ONLY COVID
STRATEGY IS TO LOCK YOU DOWN AND
MASK YOU UP, HE SAID AS MUCH
TONIGHT.
AS WE ARE SEEING WITH THE
CURRENT CASE URGING EUROPE, THAT
DOESN’T WORK!
THE TRUTH IS, JOE’S MESSAGING IS
IGNORING THE ACTUAL SIGNS.
AFTER BEING DEMONIZED BY THE
LEFT FOR OPENING UP TOO SOON,
ARIZONA AND TEXAS HAVE ALREADY
EMERGED FROM THE WORST OF IT.
THEY OF COURSE OUR FAR BETTER
OFF THAN THE DEMOCRATIC RUN
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY.
NOT MANY ARE EVEN WATCHING THE
DEMOCRAT TELETHON ORIENTED.
IF SOME NOT SURE THEY’RE GOING
TO GET THE USUAL BUMP FROM IT,
JOE’S GOOD DELIVERY
NOTWITHSTANDING.
NOW, NOT GOOD FOR JOE WHEN IN
THE KEY BATTLEGROUND STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA, BIDEN’S LEAD HAS
GONE FROM DOUBLE DIGITS TO A
MEASLY FOUR POINTS TODAY.
SO WHY THE TIGHTENING WITH ALL
THE EXCITEMENT OF THE VIRTUAL
DNC?
TODAY, JOE WAS ALL ABOUT
PRACTICING THE PROMPTER.
TRUMP WAS BACK ON THE STUMP.
>> JOE BIDEN IS NO FRIEND OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
BIDEN SUPPORTED EVERY GLOBALIST
ATTACK ON PENNSYLVANIA WORKERS.
OF MY FIRST WEEK IN OFFICE I WAS
FROM THE TRANS-PACIFIC
PARTNERSHIP WHICH WOULD BEEN
DISTRICT IF YOUR JOB A HORROR
SHOW.
I WITHDREW FROM THE ONE-SIDED
PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD WHICH WOULD
HAVE COST US SO MANY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
>> Laura: IT’S ABOUT MAKING
AMERICA SAFE AGAIN.
>> THERE IS A CERTAIN SENSE FOUR
YEARS AGO AND THESE PEOPLE HAVE
GONE INSANE.
IF YOU WANT A VISION OF YOUR
LIFE UNDER JOE BIDEN PRESIDENCY,
THINK OF THIS SMOLDERING RUINS
IN MINNEAPOLIS, THE VIOLENT
ANARCHY OF PORTLAND.
THE BLOODSTAINED SIDEWALKS OF
CHICAGO.
AND IMAGINE THE MAYHEM COMING TO
YOUR TOWN AND EVERY SINGLE TOWN
IN AMERICA.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, THE
DEMOCRATS MENTIONED NONE OF THIS
TONIGHT.
WELL, THEY COULDN’T, COULD THEY?
AMERICANS AREN’T STUPID.
NO MATTER HOW MUCH TEAM BIDEN
CHIDES TO HIDE THE BALL, THEY
KNOW THAT HE WILL KILL THE
FRACKING INDUSTRY, HE WILL
DESTROY WHAT’S LEFT OF THE STEEL
INDUSTRY WHEN HE LIFTS THE TRADE
TARIFFS ON CHINA, THEY KNOW THAT
BIDEN PRESIDENCY IMPORT MORE
CRIME AND CHEAP LABOR.
WHEN YOU WRAP YOUR MIND AROUND
THAT, SUNLIGHT JOE 45 YEAR LOVE
AFFAIR BECOMES A LOT LESS
ENDEARING OR LESS RELEVANT.
THEY THROW THE WORD DIGNITY
AROUND A LOT TONIGHT AND OVER
THE PAST FOUR NIGHTS.
TONIGHT, I WILL ASK YOU, WHERE’S
THE DIGNITY AND TAKING IN THE
AMERICAN JOB AND SHIPPING IT TO
CHINA?
WHERE’S THE DIGNITY AND
REWARDING THE LAWLESSNESS AND
SANCTUARY CITIES?
WHERE IS THE DIGNITY AMERICANS
LEFT DEFENSELESS WHEN POLICE ARE
DEFUNDED?
WHERE’S THE DIGNITY AND THE
EMPATHY AND KEEPING OUR KIDS OUT
OF THE CLASSROOM IN ORDER TO
PLACATE THE TEACHERS UNION?
WHERE’S ALL THAT COMPASSION AND
REMAINING SILENT AS OUR CITIES
ARE LEVEL BY THE DEMOCRATS MOST
VIOLENT AND CRUEL SUPPORTERS?
ANSWER?
THERE IS ZERO DIGNITY, ZERO